ذريعه يبحث عنها النظام الايراني لاعدام
السجناء السياسيين الذين يعارضون سياسته
ويطالبون بالحريه فبعد انتهاء الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه عام
1988 توغل مجاهدوا خلق في عمليه اطلق
عليها النور الابدي في محاوله للاطاحه
بالنظام الذي ضعفت قدراته بسبب الحرب مع
جارته لتمان سنوات حيث يقول محللون ان هذه
العمليه اعطت زريعه للنظام لاعدام الالاف
دوده محاكمه او ادله او حتى شهود فالخوف
والضعف كما يسيطران على نظام خميني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لنعود بالتاريخ الى عام 1988 كيف تلقيتي
خبر المجزره التي راح ضحيتها 30 الف سجين
سياسي تخيلي ناروتو كنت حزينه جدا وبكيت
كثيرا ليس فقط من اجله بل من اجل كل
الشباب الذين اعدموا عندما سمعت الاخبار
بكيت كثيرا ليس فقط على ابن عمي بل على
جميع الشباب الذين كانوا يدعمون مجاهدين
خلق لانهم جميعهم كانوا ابرياء
[موسيقى]
عندما استلم خميني الحكم عذب وسجن وقتل
الناس وكانت حربهم مع العراق ذريعه لقتل
اي شخص يعارضه واصر على الاستمرار في
الحرب المدمره مع العراق رغم انه كانت
هناك فرص كثيره لتحقيق السلام مع الجار
العراق لكنه دمر كل المصادر الايرانيه حتى
ان كثيرا من الناس خرجوا في احتجاجات وحتى
الحرس الثوري الايراني قال للنظام انهم
ليست لديهم مصادر كافيه للاستمرار في هذه
الحرب